all right this hey babe episode we got a
special guest stavros who's got a
youtube special out nobody knows how to
say stavo's lesson
our good friend hysterical comedian this
was a really really funny episode really
a funny episode he's he's one of the
huge left the podcast come town which is
a fantastic podcast we talked about time
travel we talked about look who's
talking the movie we talked about what
napoleon likes a woman yeah and uh i
thought it was great and look at our
merch we got new merch here come it's
out this is not all of it but this is
something to check out that's my
favorite shirt check out that babe look
at that hey babe unicorn baby you got
that at salvo
salvocanocomedy.com you get that christy
comedy.com get that no press network.com
yeah all of it that's yeah and i got the
hoodies we got stickers we got we got
everything baby the merch is out and um
babe this is going to be one of those
episodes it's amazing
i would say this hey babe episode is
probably the hardest you've laughed
in a long long time i agree yeah yeah i
left really hard to do that dying
laughing at the beginning of that
episode that was great it was great it
was a flu bye you guys are going to love
this app and you're going to love staff
too yeah and what also what i also think
you guys will love is my special on
netflix called specially where she's
still streaming also july 8th and 9th
providence rhode island august 18 august
17th to the 20th brea improv and
september 30th the chicago theater
chrisdcomedy.com yes and one thing we
never asked you guys to do but we would
help us if you want to help us a simple
way to help us subscribe to the no press
channel on youtube if you haven't
already and follow us on spotify and
rate us on itunes choose one of them do
you know just it's a simple thing can
help us a lot we never asked for so
we're going to start asking you guys to
do it i mean it's only fair he ain't
lying i ain't lying we just give you
this thing every week and you know you
gotta do something for us too uh salvo
cattle comedy for tour dates right now i
have 23 dates coming up uh tomorrow
night in rochester at the kodak center
saturday in syracuse at the kraus heinz
theater next weekend i'm doing that uh
tour with bert that fully loaded
festival the uh the minor league stadium
yeah awesome i'll be in south bend at
that show on june 16th and then the
pabst theater in milwaukee on june 17th
and the pantages theater in minneapolis
on june 18th
don't savage.com a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
baby
[Music]
all over your
[Music]
today we have our guest the angel known
as stablos nobody knows how to say his
language you got it it's easy you you
even put the you even put the stank on
stavros
you gave me the [ __ ] roll door you
can say houses
stavros hawkins
how do you say it when you say it
is in greek but you know if i'm not one
of those guys nothing is more annoying
to me than like a guy
who just like i understand that i appear
white so nothing's worse to me than a
[ __ ] white guy that go like a white
guy at a mexican restaurant that's like
i have the fajitas yeah right so like
even though i am green right even though
i am greek if i'm just if i'm on the
streets i'm not gonna be like oh yeah my
name is right so you're a [ __ ]
it's very romantic thank you yeah yeah
and what are people is it people call we
call you stavy baby people call you at
home stop starving
was it a very difficult name growing up
but they're like stay out for maryland
steve give your ass
i mean i grew up star burst there i
definitely had some literally my middle
school basketball trophy right and i
would they loved me i was just trying to
be a participation
i've been this height since sixth grade
okay so
i grew into my body early
um so i was [ __ ] listen i was i was
doing i was wrong i didn't make listen i
got 12 years old i am yeah yeah i got
cut immediately at high school tryouts
but i [ __ ] held it down at roland
park uh public uh uh a middle school
basketball league i'm from maryland yeah
and also my school
was played in the private school it
wasn't in the city public school league
for whatever reasons for a little
loophole so a little easier competition
right uh anyway
on my [ __ ] uh on my trophy it was
spelled staros
s-t-a-r-r-o-s
and that's just what my coach thought my
name was
star rose it was you know obviously i
was i was one of only a couple white
kids on the team
and then my high school football coach
thought my i he called everybody by
their last name okay and i was the only
one who called stop by the first i was
like oh he [ __ ] loves me he just
never bothered to find out all right
that he thought your name was like phil
stover he had no idea what my first name
was not only did he not like me not only
did did i not get special treatment he
just didn't even care to know what my
first name was jesus
coach i had a coach growing up who like
if you came in with a name like that he
would just pick another name like you
just call you mike yeah yeah what's up
mike not even a nickname yeah
yeah get on the baseline
um dude so savvy's here savvy babies
here thanks for having me a part of the
of the great hit podcast come town
that's right um and uh st obviously he's
been on the road all over doing stand-up
all over he's gonna take the summer off
sorry fellas summer off so you can't see
him in the front row that's right um but
dude we're happy we're happy to have you
we were thinking we were thinking
because we start we just only recently
started having guests on hay bay i love
that like yo dude who's more hay babe
than stop that's me yeah i see i see
those i'm just like i'm i'm pawing at my
at my uh you know when a cat or a dog
she's another dog on tv and it just
starts barking
that's me whenever i see your instagram
clips i'm like let me in there i'm i'm
one of the guys yeah
let me get to staten island you know
what i'll do i'll cut out like a doggy
door in the front door
[Laughter]
yesterday do you know what is a
fascinating
unbelievable one of the most
i think underrated movies of all time i
watched it i haven't done this maybe
ever i watched it twice in a row last
night all right let's get hints to my
family yeah once by myself in a row i
was up to one o'clock the morning
watching this movie again which i've
seen a million times which i had on vhs
at my grandfather's house to my hand
janet used to let me well oh my aunt it
was my aunt janet's vhs boom my
grandfather picked me up and i would
have to wait two hours for my mom to
come to come get me for my grandpa's
house and i watched on vhs repeatedly
came out in 198 here ready for the house
okay
1989 okay debuted in 1989 okay uh
looks like it was shot in new york but
actually shot in vancouver right okay
classic and uh okay so it's not willow
and bruce willis is a talking baby
die hard four die hard
look who's talking baby wow you're
really rich do you rich you re original
i saw it in the theater i remember that
dude look who's talking from start to
finish is a
banger of a movie i love that you ran it
back that's awesome
that's beautiful watching with your
family that's one thing that's great but
back to just just you well twice in a
row and then my kids are watching it you
know my daughter's seven you know the
first scene the guy just blows a load
inside kirstie allen you know really
that's how it starts and then they're
just sperm
orange slices i was like those are
orange slices because i'm like what am i
supposed to say then
30 seconds later it's just it's just
it's just uh sperm and she goes this
thing and she goes what are those i was
like those are tadpoles wow and then she
goes and then she says to me she goes
why is it getting inside the orange and
i said that's how you make orange juice
and she was like what so this morning
before she went to school she asked for
a tadpole at an orange because she said
when she gets home today she wants to
make orange juice with the family i love
i was like i tried to make orange juice
with your mother last night
and i got denied shut up
i love how quickly your stupid lie came
back to haunt you right away it wasn't
even one week later it was shinsy orange
juice at the grocery store like oh let's
do that right now
then the baby and if you look at the
bait like the you know for 1989 it was
good but the baby literally looks like
it was burned in a fire like this baby
looks like it has skin grafts on his
face when it comes out you mean yeah no
like when it's moving
the baby like before like you know as
soon as um you know uh like whatever
she's eight months pregnant seven months
pregnant they have cameras inside the
uterus talking to the baby the baby it
literally looks like it looks not that
baby that baby that's a real baby normal
it's pg-13 it's a pg-13 move but this
baby looked the makeup in 1989's means
the best they could do yeah who's trying
to make an in a a baby in the uterus but
it's a horrifying looking
claymation oh yeah this this is horrible
this one this one's not as bad it's when
it's really like eight months old when
it's like just about to be born eight
nine months i mean i hate that dude this
is terrifying that stinks yeah i'm i
went from pro choice to pro abortion
because of this
i want this thing
i want this thing taken care of
don't bring that little [ __ ] up thing
into the world
i forget like it was the movie did we
follow the baby dog
because then it was look who's
wait so is it their babies every time
yes well this no at the end of look
who's talking john travolta and kirstie
alley have a baby of their own a girl
that's who look who's talking to but
what's that i mean of their own who's
the first baby the first baby is she she
hasn't uh she's in an affair with her
boss she's singing
that dude george siegel is the boss he
cheats on his wife oh that's george
singles balls wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait oh so that's right john
travolta is in this john travolta is the
camp driver that takes kirsty alley to
them yes they
she has this baby out of wed yes then
they have a baby together that's part
two yeah what's part three part three is
i don't know part three i'm gonna watch
part three yeah yeah yeah
dude
delicious
another great love
i'm giving him a [ __ ] name i'm gonna
name him like pericles or some [ __ ] like
that oh i'm going like yeah that's dope
actually
this is kind of cool i don't like
periscope you go to greece even
archimedes yeah exactly
well that's a little tricky because the
way you say balls in greek is atheia so
archimedes
it would just be he would be like ball
you know balls would be a lot of work
for saying that's like that's like humor
does a joke about this she un didn't do
you know amy schumer's baby's name she
didn't realize that she did this because
she loves dave attell yeah so much you
know as we all do and yeah i think it
might be the godfather for a kid or
something but she named her kid he's the
father actually oh david davis that's
right she named her kind of a george
single christianity situation
and then whatever the husband's last
name is jean attel so she was like he
was like two months old and i was like i
named my kid genital
yeah
he was two months old that he had to
legally change his middle name she's
like i messed up that's so [ __ ] funny
she was doing a bit about it that's
gonna hurt a comedian's feelings it's
like if you're getting bumped from the
middle name
[Laughter]
it's seinfeld now it's gene seinfeld's
seinfeld
it's jean red skelton
she goes i'm gonna change it to gene
cosby
damn i gotta change
[Laughter]
but look who's talking what you know the
movie it's so good because first of all
it's like the story it holds up you
laughed you you laughed through it and
it was probably a tight ninety right huh
probably like a tight 90 minutes 90
minutes and you knew how to make that's
make them short make you know make them
a nice one of those things where i
realized like 85 going 88 88 i love you
like like good jokes not really a lot of
cursing kind of relatively clean family
can watch it like i bet you if we just
do that like that's what people want now
because i realize like morality is very
much down now in the world so it's like
when you all right yeah
birth control
i gotta take my meds i'm sorry
that's what that is
so so it was just like it was just like
i was like watching this movie i was
like yeah there's a lip there's stuff
for adults where it's like you know you
gotta explain to my kids like what the
sperm and the orange slice egg is
whatever that makes you ha that forces
you to have that conversation
immediately in a good way and then it's
like yeah if you're a good father yeah
it opens up a natural opportunity to
teach your curious daughter about how
humans reproduce but instead you say
something makes almost no sense
baby frogs in an orange make orange
juice
yeah you're right that makes almost no
sense
there's a couple of things here
i guess i can see the tadpoles swimming
around maybe you turn the orange they
liquefy it with their little tails you
know i'm trying to help you out here
yeah i know dude i i completely messed
up on the explanation i should have just
went with the truth which is what my
mother said you know he's like why don't
you just tell the truth i was like do i
ever tell the truth
when a woman asked me a question i'm i'm
conditioned to lie
when a man loves a woman uh
yeah
we the orange juice
he gets a funnel and some uh [ __ ] uh
sunny d yeah
steps to the pet store
puts a couple on fertilized frog eggs
i was like
explaining uh the birds and the beasts
to a kid uh and i was like you know okay
this is how you do you know when a man
loves a woman
a stork
explain it
do you guys ever do this like i googled
their ages kirsty ali in this movie was
37 and john travolta was 34. oh it's
when they're doing this movie and then i
start to reflect on me i'm like i'm not
even close to being in look who's
talking yeah you know what i mean i
couldn't be a look who's talking
yesterday yeah yeah like i am not i am
not even close to you honestly you could
be the voice of the new baby and look
who's talking i could see that well we
were trying to figure it out directed
directly direct director
about the voice of the baby i think you
have bruce willis quality bruce willis
or whoever made the movie if you're
listening we know that you are i'd like
to voice the baby shout out bruce willis
by the way
god bless you god bless
bruce willis some tadpoles got in his
orange that's what happened
apples were swimming around his brain
right now yeah shout out voiceovers
shout out i mean you know is there an
easier job is it i know the best
especially now especially now back in
the day bruce willis had to go to a
studio and do that so there might have
been something i had to say half an hour
traffic now he could literally voice
look who's talking from his living room
no problem he'd be sitting got the mics
got everything we used to do that when
we had to do like little eight like
little ladies for the show like oh no
i just like don't they just have to call
me into the city to go in for like an
hour and be like look at that
be like don't ever do this weekend so
like on set when i was done for the day
i started going just keep my mic going
oh no
look out
joe's up like and then i would just be
like don't [ __ ] call me and now they
just like like i it on my phone and just
send it to them just also just have any
guy say those things right no one is
going to give a single [ __ ]
no one's playing it back no one's
watching in practical jokers for the adr
being spot on you know what i mean like
but yeah anyway you know what i noticed
too about look who's talking is john
travolta even though he's a heartthrob
never takes his shirt off in this movie
and that's what you are now maybe i
should play him then
and those movie in these movies back in
the 80s there wasn't it didn't have to
be that scene where everyone's half
naked even when kirstie alley's getting
banged out where they're showing [ __ ]
going down her
uterus yeah that she's not naked she's
not they show it's very classy it's
scientific it's scientific yeah it's
zoomed so far in it's not offensive dude
and even like dude there's a scene but i
mean the guy george siegel the you know
the the father
can't place him george siegel google
george segal you've seen this guy he's
just passed away yeah um you've seen him
among this guy a million
he was in uh just shoot me right he was
in that move i just watched the movie he
was in those [ __ ] see this guy before
in your lifestyle
you've never seen this guy he's not
ringing a bell oh dude this guy rules he
i just watched an almond movie that he
was in with um
another another [ __ ] hot jew from the
70s
[ __ ]
70s
let's find it can pimp find it from the
70s you can find them you can definitely
find them
um [ __ ] what the guy what the [ __ ] i'm
so i'm sorry i've been doing thousands
of things like no he's insanely yeah
this guy you know you know who just
passed away the guy who played remote
williams fred ward
the adventures of whatever the
adventures of remo williams
what is
coming up for a hot you from the 70s
yeah also we're gonna mail we're gonna
have to we're gonna make it mailed out
bro by the way we i went down somewhere
there's nobody no is that green
and this is the 70s is key email the
podcast hey baepanachima.com who's the
hottest jew from the 70s
well look he's not traditionally uh [ __ ]
i can't believe i'm blanking on his name
he rules uh he's not traditionally
handsome he's like uh or he is he is
handsome but he's not he's not like
ripped or anything he's got a little
lanky you know what i mean
the guy from the 70s yeah from the 70s
i'm saying i was sexually attracted to
him in the movie
what movie what movie it was
it was a
it was with george siegel it was a poker
movie
uh
it was a robert altman movie
uh [ __ ] it was good i also was what
i've been doing the last i've had four
days off and i've just been california
split [ __ ] sick movie one of those
elliot gould
gold is from the 70s
[Laughter]
do you mean look at that [ __ ] guy by
the way the name of this episode 70's
jill
[Laughter]
belly ghoul is a piece of ash hello
goodbye you ever seen that that's a
[ __ ] did you just pass away elliot
cool no i just watched that movie it's
fine yeah he's doing all right how's
that only at cool's health actually that
looks a little like sam moreau right
there he looks really like maybe i want
to [ __ ] someone who's going to play
elliot gold in the movie oh my god yes
we set it here first we set it here
first who's going to play who in the
movie
just in interest
for some reason young young elliot gold
has time travel to current day staten
island where he finds a baby
i went down yeah because here's what
happened to me because we were talking
before the show started i now am off the
road until july 8th the 9th providence
rhode island well i think it's sold out
but oh i'm going to providence i'm in
providence uh in a couple of weeks go
see stop see me baby i think i only got
a couple tickets left for the friday
shows actually yeah i'm almost sold out
too go there and um and uh and and yeah
so so but i got these um i've had time
off right so i went down i i've never
done a lot of people do this now you
know our age our generation instead of
watching netflix or hbo whatever they
watch youtube they just go down youtube
wormholes pimp would always tell me like
i go down wormholes for three hours i
never did that i was never the guy not
one of those guys either but i've the
last week that's what i've been doing
for entertainment instead of putting on
a show
instead of putting on anything
especially on netflix especially i've
been watching i've been watching youtube
going down these wormholes and dude i
found a video it's pimpy it's called the
doddleston messages
d-o-d-l-e that's what he's watching on
youtube
messages yeah people like these cat
videos
okay okay so what let me explain to you
what happened listening is in 1985
computers started to kind of happen
right and they used to use
and then you see yours we all know that
like landmark date and time we're in
1985
started to happen
so they just they just came out of
nowhere so so
in england in this town in england they
had like
a lot of the computers like the country
gave computers to like this one section
of england for whatever reason and used
to use like a lot of energy like
computers are such a bigger deal and
when they would leave this computer on
like on uh you know like whatever yeah
it's like the screen go what do you call
it like when you just leave saver idle
computer idle computer idle messages
from this guy's claiming he was in 1546
wow started to appear he was speaking in
the right old english saying donaldson
yeah he said he said donaldson messages
he was the guy from 1546 was saying he
could just speak into this smoke and it
was giving he was just talking and then
he would receive messages back in the
smoke and was able to decipher it and
then they're talking to this guy for
form even the government is like they
believe this because like how is it then
the donald somehow
somehow one of the guys in 1985 who's
speaking in the computer he goes he goes
to back to the to the person who's
living in 1546 he says he says to him um
well uh you know in 1985 we don't have
that whatever just that's the first time
they mentioned what year they were in he
goes night and the guy from 1546 like
1985 i thought you were from 2109 when
the blight people came and gave me this
smoke they're from 2109 i thought you
were from 2011
so it's like this future past time
travel thing then the people from 2109
get involved
in our secret they're like now that our
secret is you know you know now that
they told you that like you know we time
travel you time travel becomes a thing
in like
you know 2090 and so we are able to go
back in time so i know it's very
difficult
it's 20 22 that's eight to 68 years from
now we're not going to see it we're not
going to see it probably oh and by the
way
through that so that was sick but a lot
of people think it's a hoax i do not
think if you don't have the you don't
doesn't have a you don't know that's
what it is of course
of course there's no what happened was
is that there was no there was no
deciphering it all right this podcast
sponsored by better help better help
folks talk about what burnout means to
you sal what does burnout mean to you it
means uh look i'm going i i don't know
how to say no i'm going at it from every
angle it's the job it's the family it's
the friends it's the it's all my things
no means no no means no and sometimes i
have to take a timeout and i really have
to work on my mental health really well
well better health and breakdown which
we both do better help online therapy
wants to remind you to prioritize who
yourself yourself kid talking with
someone can help you figure out what's
causing stress in your life better help
is what literally it's helping thousands
upon thousands of people get through
burnout get through other mental health
conditions we all got something we all
got something and what better help is
it's customized online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to
uh it's much more affordable than in
person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours the
thing is here look we've they've been
with us for so long better help and the
reason is is because a lot of our
listeners are trying it yes and they see
that and that they're staying with us so
if of all of our listeners are trying it
you know as well as we you know you've
tried it when it first you know i don't
know when was the last time i know you
logged on but i know when we first got
this we started using it and look it's
just if we've asked for it try it out
there's nothing to lose uh our listeners
get 10 off the first month at
betterhelp.com hey babe right that's
better h-e-l-p
dot com slash hey babe
look what sound i'm making
you're making i know what you're making
that's the sale of uh that's the sound
of a sale on shopping that's the sound
of shopify that's it
hey babe
shopify what it does is gives
entrepreneurs like yourself like your
mama the resources once reserved for big
business so upstarts startups and
established businesses alike can sell
everywhere synchronize online and
in-person sales and effortlessly stay
informed look it helps you scale your
business uh it's the only scale i'll
step on that's right
shopify powers millions of businesses
from first sale to full scale they can
reach customers online across social
networks with an ever-growing suite of
channel and channel integrations and
apps right including facebook instagram
tick tock pinterest you could use
shopify within all of those apps
synchronize all your sales across all
your platforms even in person sales get
insights and reports as you grow your
business so you can understand where
you're headed and what you need it's
more than a store it grows with you goes
with you it's a possibility this is
possibility powered by shopify and i'm
so excited to tell you that listen
that sound that you hear is don't worry
about it's just a diabetic go to shopify
chris
go to shopify shopify.com hey vape all
lowercase don't put an uppercase letter
in there for a free 14-day trial and get
full
access to shopify's entire suite of
features grow your business with shopify
today go to shopify.com hey babe right
now shopify.com slash hey babe
there's no solve no that they what did
you want to happen
the guy from 1546 then says i'm i'm i'm
getting removed from my land
i'm i'm getting i'm going to write a
book i'm getting generated about this
i'm going to write a book about this but
because i can be hung for heresy or
burned at the stake for heresy in my
time i'm going to hide this book
detailing everything but you'll find it
and then still to this day it hasn't
been found nobody's found it but the the
piece of land that they were on
is cause he was saying this guy was
saying that his name was i forgot what
his name was not gary but
yeah all his stuff like sound like 1546
yeah was he not was he like bro i'm
telling you no no he was like do it
through the night
on yonder
yeah but he says he says you know and
then he says um you know so they're
looking up his name they can't find his
name and whatever and blah blah blah
like maybe this is a hoax but then he
says in one of his final messages goes i
i wasn't able to give you my real name
because again if i get caught with this
like this is witchcraft this is heresy
like in old english so then he gives his
real name of the spelling and it's
[ __ ] that guy john lennon yes yes
dude it's george siegel
it's
he said he goes
he says um whatever his name was thomas
hardin thomas howard they look up the
the
the stuff and he was there he lived
there and they said the last five years
of his life he went insane around 15 45
47 claiming that he was speaking to some
people from the future and some people
some people from the future and that he
was able to communicate blah blah blah
and they burned them at the stake for
which
bro because a lot of people think it's a
hoax and that's what you that's what i'm
realizing on the internet when i really
get down that's where the truth is dude
that's where the truth is i'm literally
i'm
[Laughter]
this guy was saying that people from the
future are coming back
like they're coming back to 1506. i love
the idea that like they're like why
don't we go why don't we go blow off
some steam where rape is still legal
like just racist they want to be sex
criminals they're like 1500s the blacks
were slaves
[ __ ] were in their place that's where
i'm going on vacation
i'm not going to the bahamas i'm going
back a thousand years ago to commit sex
they're living in their life they can't
get any [ __ ] you know because of the
[ __ ] supply chain issues they can't
get anyone to put up the lumber they go
back they get an indentured servant they
rip them out they're like you build that
i'll pay you in bread and then they
throw them back and throw it down
exactly dude they give them a [ __ ]
they give them a stuffed crust pizza and
their brain explodes
they're going back they're going back to
1546 trading doritos
did you read it in bruce willis look
this is
i'm not sure if this is from 1546 or
just the way pimp spells
pimp jotted that down real quick
was it on his farm of oak and stone it
is helpful that you should tell me about
that this is not 1500 what the [ __ ] i
will say is some [ __ ]
was parentheses around in 1546 well
that's the thing there is some linguist
that comes in who says yes the words
because some they got like a [ __ ]
linguist that would like support their
theory that was like yeah this is a
hundred percent it blah blah blah blah
blah blah yeah you know but meanwhile
the ghost is writing like hashtag lit
like right right right but but then
another linguist a more like educated
linguist a woman because some dumb guy
is like yeah this is funny yeah this is
surreal
and then some woman from like oxford
like one of the top linguists in the
world in 1985 was like this couldn't be
more of a hoax you said yes the words
match but the verbs which is what
language is is the verbiage is all wrong
yeah this is [ __ ] i mean i have seen
it for 30 seconds i'm it's clearly not
from 1500s this is some [ __ ] guy off
reddit he didn't even like look up
fifteen hundreds like fifteen fourteen
you can't even you wouldn't even be able
to [ __ ] make it well like look at
look at the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] another
bridge shakespeare right we wouldn't
even be able to know what the [ __ ] the
couple that kept seeing it all
it was the
woman's name was debbie but only these
messages pretty much only happened when
debbie was there and then when they
would have he's like deb you got to help
me yeah when the scientist was saying it
never happened
well now maybe the ghost was trying to
get [ __ ] you know
he was like
he's like [ __ ] only no
can i tell you something but right now
if you you we just people now that don't
speak proper grammar or english no no so
what about back then it could be the
same thing that's a good that's that
would be even less intelligible it
wouldn't they wouldn't speak wrong
to a way that's closest for us to
understand they wouldn't be speaking
wrong into the future let me ask you
this do you think you'd have a better
chance of understanding more words from
someone from 1546 or kodak black right
now
he's from 1546
that's interesting i would say if i'm
also uh sipping on lean i think i could
figure it out figure it out if i have if
i have some some cough syrup in my
system i could figure it out but i also
want the gold grills
by the way 79
napoleon bonaparte to josephine
bonaparte i once went on a date with a
girl who told me she
exclusively masturbated to napoleon
bonaparte's letters to his wife to his
[ __ ] side piece i was like what is it
oh you're a fan of history i know you
love fish she goes
like as she was like i masturbate to
napoleon bonaparte's letter wasn't his
letter wasn't were in his sex letters
about how stinky
he wanted
was he like don't shower i want it
[ __ ] ripe did he believe so well
let's see a few days ago
you're playing this so straight and i
can't tell you i'm not joking
part of the letters
i'm pretty sure
at least there's one famous there's one
yeah you have a lot of beeps in this one
look at that
hey follow
ready for this french colloquialism
referring to the aroma and residue of an
unwashed vagina napoleon bonaparte has
repeated to have asked josephine to not
bathe while he was away at battle so
that he would be able to enjoy her role
model see that castle
that's right
there's certain things i got a little
this is the kind of stuff i know and
that's what she's that's what she's
masturbating to yeah yeah stinky ass in
the [ __ ] and by the way this is 18th
century stinky
can you imagine you don't even know we
don't really know
it would it would cinch our arm hair off
yeah even even napoleon's girlfriend
with the [ __ ] right everyone smell bad
in the middle ages this is a great
question you rise the battle i have to
be right town
by the end of the middle ages it is
likely that majority of people smell
pretty bad too you know what's
interesting fact about the middle ages
it's christians you know like on the
crusades christians we were like
disgusting like didn't bathe for months
like likes just monsters but muslims
when we got to constantinople and uh
middle east they were clean clean as
well they were clean using these days
over the years clean clean clean spices
and all that it was christmas that was
disgusting no because the first bath and
body works was in uh it was in jerusalem
it was in uh was in iraq yeah yeah yeah
mesopotamia that was the fun that was
the cradle of civilization but i'm
telling you man going down these time
travel things or like what people say
about like what the future will look
like what it'll be like one video was
saying how like florida is going to be
gone by 2025 because of coastal flooding
i can see how africa is gonna get
flooded and be separated into three
different parts of the continent and all
these things and how this is why
billionaires are buying land it is like
a fact in like montana all the
billionaires are buying land it's not an
american problem this is a world thing
every desert every high plain desert in
the world
95
plus of the land is being bought out by
billionaires and nobody really knows why
it all started about five years ago
that's such just elon musk
the only two places are going to be able
to be because they said the the most
likely scenario is a polar shift is a is
a north north and south pole are going
to come out of whack and like the elect
like the magnetic field or whatever is
going to start melting uh all the polar
ice caps and it's going to start causing
insane storms and flooding they said the
only two places that are going to be
habitable
pretty much the entire continent of
australia will be untouched somehow
and antarctica is going to be released
from ice and that's going to be the land
where like people can survive so they
said if you can make that's it they said
if you can make it inland in the desert
they said most likely just like the
asteroid hit and wiped out the dinosaurs
and and this has happened many times in
in the earth's history about 90 of the
population is going to be wiped out so
10 of the population will be able to fit
on antarctica in australia and then they
grow from there which is it it's
happened to every animal so
it's unlikely it doesn't happen tonight
how much time we talk in here 100 years
400 years old
[Laughter]
right yeah it's
been on my podcast money i know
i don't think that way because i'm
already so messed up in my head that i
can't afford to carry that around of
course but yeah we are a blip we are
nothing i mean we're going to be we're
going to be i mean we're going to be
googling us right like we just did the
dotted
messages
but what these videos were saying which
is interesting is that like you know it
it nobody no group of people thought
they'd ever be wiped out it's just it's
just how our brains are but it ha it's
nobody can escape it it's just going to
happen now when is it going to happen
some scientists say we're overdue for an
asteroid hit we're overdue for this
happening you're talking asteroids not
global warming they said asteroids
global warming you know nuclear war some
people think it is what's going to be
global warming it's going to probably be
global warming but they were saying that
like also you know
if you if you um kind of just wipe us
away right
they think that it might have happened
like four or five times already because
if you wipe us away in just a hundred
years like the earth will start to take
back this apartment oh yeah he'll start
to take it back it'll be unreal in ten
thousand years it's completely buried
underneath a new mound right a million
years there's no recollection like the
scientists think if you go some
scientists if you go to like close close
to the core of the earth which no one's
been to you might find like a [ __ ]
laptop from a million years ago and
these are the same scientists that said
the uh the ghost was from fifteen
hundreds right i'm the same guy he's a
language slash dude and you know what
i'm watching all these youtube videos
and then it just suggested look who's
talking
behind the scenes
the messages there was one when you
typed them it said debunked and i would
love to see did you read that okay yeah
no i i don't want to i don't read stuff
from the haters
[Music]
so pimp just pulled up something that is
it says this is mind-bending and this is
astrobiologists
suggest the earth itself may be an
intelligent entity but
are you like me have you had enough of
astrobiologists though dude
before like
and we're like we can't hang out i'd be
like dude shut up get out of here shut
your mouth pick one astrology or biology
yeah you're doing too much right now or
against astronomy so what is interesting
is with that stuff a lot of science now
is going towards oh like are we all just
figments of our own imagination like i
was watching a scientist talk and i
don't even know how if i when i say this
if i i don't understand it but maybe you
guys sure maybe maybe
no no no stop i think if anybody
from the very future or the very past
but not right now i don't know you're
certainly not in the present yeah
so he was saying that this guy was
saying i think it was on uh joe rogan's
podcast was saying that sal you hungry
yes i am babe i got i'm always hungry i
got two two words for you
door
dash door dash never before did i like
double d that much i l i've been loving
double d since dolly parton i use door
dash all the time i think it's one of
the biggest revolutionary inventions of
our the last 10 years people don't
realize now that you could just tap on
your phone with it you don't have to get
on the phone with somebody yeah okay and
you don't even have to have an
interaction when the person delivers and
it's not it's not just food from a
restaurant you can now get groceries and
other essential items to live with door
there so it it's beyond it's it's it is
beyond it's beyond i used door dish last
night to order from where did we order
from
last night
a restaurant here called blue i ordered
door dash last night delivered it to me
i would never said bloom no no no
with over 3 000 partners you can support
your neighborhood go-to's or choose from
your favorite national restaurants like
things like pop by chipotle and
cheesecake fries yeah for a limited time
our listeners get 25 percent off viente
esenco off and zero delivery fees
on their first order of 15 or more when
you download the door dash app and enter
the code hey babe that's 25 off up to 10
value and zero delivery fees on your
first order when you download the door
dish app in the app store and enter code
hey babe do not forget that's code hey
babe for 25 off your first order with
doordash subject
terms apply babe let's talk about
policies let's do it okay what is policy
genius policy genius is a marketplace
that helps insurance shoppers understand
their options compare quotes across
multiple insurance companies and buy a
policy all in one place
wow so all home are all homeowners okay
rising inflation insurance rates are
concerning but did you know one of the
easiest ways to save money is by
re-shopping home and auto and auto
insurance i didn't know that policy
genius customers saved an average of 1
250 per year over what they were paying
for home and auto insurance if you
already have home and auto coverage uh
if your policies are up for renewal and
your cost costs have increased policy
genius can help you look for the lower
rates basically you're just going to go
on here and whereas you would have to
search every single insurance company or
call people from multiple quotes you're
gonna get all that information to you
right in one shot policy genius is your
one-stop shop to find and buy the
insurance you need head to
policygenius.com to get started policy
genius will show you price estimates for
policies that fit your search if you
like what they find that gets switched
over for free wow
customers who bundled their home and
auto policies with policy genius saved
an average of you said this 1250 per
year over what they were paying okay
yeah policy genius has saved new
customers an average of 350
per year on home insurance so it's a
no-brainer listen policy gsr has earned
thousands of five-star reviews across
google and trustpilot and they don't
sell your info to third parties head to
policygenius.com to get your free home
and auto insurance quotes and see how
much you could save
okay so the units i love this i love
that we've gone from a youtube video you
watched to a remembered thing from a
different podcast
how quickly even the very flimsy
evidence you have is getting even lower
on the totem pole this episode has been
off the rails from the beginning this is
hey babe we're supposed to knock her so
we get that hello my bad
no we're too much no we don't
napoleon's girlfriend's blue cheese
fresh
so so what they said was though and i
again i was kind of blown my my i i've
also been taking edibles almost every
morning me too bro i'm going to be
getting me out of alcohol i've been
taking a bite a micro dose just a little
bite of an animal to take you out of
alcohol i don't want to drink alcohol
anymore so i've been taking a little
vitamin e
in the morning like micro dosing the
littlest bite and i've got to be honest
with you dude i have been in a mode of
accepting and not resisting for the past
week like like you can't even imagine
i'm just accepting anything that comes
down
can i get some head it's got excuse me
can i get can i get some head let's test
this theory
[Laughter]
he really does
[Laughter]
much
[Laughter]
i just saw
oh my god that's that's david bowie's
line i love it
so
yeah what what is that lion somebody's
just giving these lions haircuts he
looks sick dude honestly oh my god so
funny dude so okay so what they said
about the universe was is that
we can't see the end of the universe
like we can only see
to the edge of it on what
[Laughter]
it looks awesome
[Laughter]
sick this it's a sick look honestly so
um
yeah yeah okay so we can only see the
edge of course don't see the edge
because because
light
you know nothing like speed of light
right so you can only see light you can
only see where the we can get up to the
light so we can only catch up to the
light can't go faster so the universe
they think is like ever expanding like
it's expanding forever and that we can
only see to the edge of the universe on
on again our instruments but
out past the light which we have no
capability of seeing there could be
other universes far more advanced than
ours or as advanced as ours or behind
ours whatever yeah we genuinely have no
way of knowing and they're that
therefore they're saying even like the
universe itself might only look like it
looks like and exists like it looks like
because we're here to measure it so if
we weren't here to measure it it might
look like
completely different or be completely
different and i'm like so like that's
why when pimp pulls up things like earth
you know astrobiologists think earth is
just like some kind of like sentient
illusion or whatever it's like yeah and
i think we're only starting i think like
this in life you know like in the 1700s
they went to like an enlightenment
period like all these things that like
we know now are like yeah of course you
dumb [ __ ] yeah yeah we don't really your
son doesn't roll around right absolute
[ __ ] flies don't just appear out of
[ __ ] yeah like
yeah but like elon musk of that day was
like yeah definitely 100 the earth's
flat yeah you know
you're like no you dummy i'm raising a
billion dollars to get to the edge of
the earth
where now
i just i'm just i have some light
machinery running it's
i like what okay said that uh we're kind
of the earth's immune system or cancer
cells oh yeah good yeah we're definitely
cancer you're not questioning yeah i'm
without question we're doing way more
bad than good well no i mean dude
human beings we've killed i think what
is it 99 percent of living thing of
things you've lived with 99 percent
that's good dude that's better than aids
that's true um trees are t cells yeah
and we got that we got the [ __ ]
chainsaws out we need ikea furniture
suck my dick brazil
the rainforest could eat my ass
i need a mound bookcase and i need
and loaded
oh here we go yeah we know her
fart you don't want to listen to the
haters though right because i did want
to
let's listen to the haters
um let's listen to the haters um but
before we listen to haters real quick
since we're on the topic of youtube i do
feel like i should get the actual reason
i'm here out quickly
which is that i have a special i don't
know when this is coming out but it
either my special either just came out
or it's coming out in two weeks it's
coming it's coming out a week and a half
not this week next week okay so my
special is on youtube right now called
live at the lounge room um that i'm out
40k on this [ __ ] i need you guys
to watch it i probably need a hundred
million views to make my money back if i
had to guess yeah let's get it let's go
after it let's go after it uh but it's
possible uh by the time you're listening
it's a smash hit i've been drafted i'm
actually now the baby and look who's
talking for
i was off the of the success of my debut
special live at the lodge room go to my
youtube channel
uh just my name starburst cause i post a
bunch of stand up there but yes the
special i want people to see it
fans will watch it for sure see how it's
funny people put in the link in the
description on this video and everything
you you guys are the best thank you so
yeah let's get let's get to the haters
let's get today's oh really one other
thing too i just want to mention quickly
about going to this wormhole is that
they think also another real likely
likely thing that's going to happen is a
lot of people will go to mars like
that's going to just be a thing and no
but and and habit habitat mars and then
what's going to be interesting is when
but they'll come back it's not like
they'll just want to put humans to live
there or what's time share oh yeah
exactly
but over like the course of like 100
years because there's like 30 or 40
percent less gravity on mars people are
going to become a lot taller no taller
because there's less pressure in their
spine so their spine expands so the
average human the average male
in we're shorter because gravity is
pulling us down yes the average they're
going to be taller and weaker though too
a little weaker but the average male
in 1800 was five seven they were saying
if we lived on mars for a hundred years
the average male by like twenty one
hundred would be six seven wow so that's
why so that and that's why like when a
lot of people think they see aliens they
see very tall beings because there's no
gravity they it's they think it's a
gravitational thing that's why every
gravity makes you talk so they have
people why are we taller now though is
there less gravity huh why are we taller
than nutrition nutrition okay but but
they they have actually nasa has people
now that
there's people out there now that are
living for science living in like zero
gravity
places to see what it does to their body
they just volunteer to be like i'll do
it they want to do it yeah they want to
give back to science that's a lot
interesting i would do it that's asking
a lot
my guess they don't got a lot going on
yeah you know what i mean shit's not
going good they dropped out of community
college maybe dishonorably discharged
from the military they set them up with
a [ __ ] ps5 yeah all the seamless they
want if i could have buffalo wild wings
if my career was failing and you tell me
i get as much playstation buffalo wild
wings and maybe they may be a prostitute
every month right you would do it you're
dedicating your entire body to science
that's it you become although you know
would be annoying they'd probably want
you to be healthy there's no chance i'm
going to be able to die in zero gravity
because like what's the point i get to
be fat as [ __ ] like float around
yeah
gravity affects many parts of your body
as you age it compresses the spine
contributes to poor blood circulation
and decrease your flexibility that's why
i'm [ __ ] um i'm grabbing aches and
pains yeah dude i've been i've been
living in too much gravity that's right
um but um do a zero grave
what is zero gravity like uh like a t
like sleep depth like one of those no
not the chambers no well that that i
mean that that you kind of feel like
your flow do you ever go into those
chambers
and you just float yeah man it's wild is
it a is it a therapeutic thing it's just
for fun i don't know
but i know fatone did it and he just
like literally floated around the room
that's sick like not one of those things
where like the air blows you up like he
went into zero graff that's gotta be
only [ __ ] nasa has access i think so
we got invited to nasa i wonder if they
would have let us do it
where is nasa is it in houston alabama
no houston houston we have a problem
right yeah i think it's houston yeah
shout out tom hanks
shout out to nasa all right so you want
you want to debunk the donaldson
messages you want to go to the haters
do we even need to bother i mean clearly
i want to see if it was true yeah
i want to see like what the gotcha
moment was though yeah like what if they
found the guy like you know yeah yeah
well they think it was this woman debbie
it because it's 100 debbie yeah the
messages only came to her no scientists
ever saw it the [ __ ] is barely disguised
in olding it's not even old english she
just put twas thigh in that kind of [ __ ]
yeah
yeah she's talking like a like a milady
guy like a reddit guy a guy with a
fedora she's talking about things that
happen in the 80s like whitney houston
yeah absolutely she's like i'm dying of
aids
the thine queen concert was positively
ravishing
fredwood mercury
fred ward
yeah no this is so [ __ ] fake so what
do we got here anything you should just
watch look who's talking three and stuff
yeah
we should watch look who's talking three
and and do the commentary for it i would
love that you have to do a lot
you want to stay for the next spot
that's what i gotta do if i get another
pot i would love to
plan this out i would 100 have done that
dude look at this did you see that guy
that wiped cake on the mona lisa yeah
how much jail time is he going to get
for that i mean you can't do that yeah
it wasn't on the thing right it's got
his own glasses so then who gives a [ __ ]
exactly they can even arrest him for
that then i think he was
trying to bring uh i think he was
actually trying to bring attention to
climate change or something like that
yeah dressed as a woman he's kind of
like the will smith of the art world now
now every protester is going to try to
slap the painting that's true yeah yeah
chris rock yeah yeah yeah this is an
attack on all paintings
we must cherish our beautiful paintings
were you guys i don't mean to that was
hilarious and everybody was like we have
to protect comedians as if we're not the
biggest [ __ ] retards in the world
there isn't one class of entertainer
that deserves to be slapped more than us
we deserve it my job like what has
helped my career the most is
finding people i don't know and just
ridiculing everything about them
destroying their i deserve to be like if
one if a guy talked like that to me
there's a good chance somebody like you
know i'm prepared for getting slapped
you know it's like we're not special it
was so funny this backlash that happened
that was like right how this is gonna
and the idea that you're important
enough that some [ __ ] guy is going to
slap you with [ __ ] you know the funny
bone you know what i mean like it's the
oscars bro and somebody else was like oh
do you ever worry about like somebody
like shooting up a comedy club i'm like
the comedians are the biggest i'd be
worried about the comedian shooting the
audience that's the way bigger
probability yes yeah every time
someone's on tour and they come to your
city
the most mentally ill person in that
city just arrives dude every time
there's a mass shooting and they show up
a pic they show a picture of the guy i'm
like i saw that guy zany
commercial what racist would would would
be this is recent pimp yeah this is uh i
think over the weekend oh okay so what i
mean we know voss he's not racist what's
he talking about his band from team voss
i haven't read it yet and we're going to
read this like
rich
balls was almost immediately turned up
by comedian rich foster's set which
included what she called target
harassment toward a table of indigenous
women can we just read what [ __ ] boss
said that's the lesson
here we go
let me he goes one of the things he said
was listen lady i'm not your sponsor you
need to go to your next a meeting he was
making a joke about a talent show and
saying that you know these ladies would
likely come up and make dream catchers
the american community also made a joke
about hoping the women would get
ticketed for driving under the efforts
on the way home which perpetuated
offensive stereotypes okay
the stereotype is that uh native native
people are drunks basically that's you
don't know that one no that's a that's a
classic
she was outside the auditorium look and
although she was outside the auditorium
for part of her set lanigan says she
could hear voss continuous comments
about the women oh lady shut up he was
on a roll
guys listen look at his face that guy is
not racist
dude
the one that he said that caused the
table to go he goes right that's it
we've had enough and stand up and walk
out in unison was he said they should
all go back to their [ __ ] wigwam
all right he was he was on one
i mean but
he was on one
he was on a little heater there with
that one
listen and honestly this statement right
here could be literally any review of a
rich voss show it was very clearly
racist and nobody was really laughing
it just felt like full-on racial attacks
especially against the indigenous
community that might be from voss's bio
like literally what are you talking
about lady you went to a rich voice yeah
they took that from the stress factory
website he's there next weekend
what they didn't show is that he did
that to every single person in the crowd
no matter what they're freaking out
to read the people who loved it i bet
you there's somebody out there like
that's for indigenous i was like yeah i
laughed my ass off we can't even like
kind of laugh well at our like that's so
annoying people people have said this we
can't laugh at ourselves
people have said this so many times
where it's like
people go to comedy shows they're like
oh i want to go to a comedy show but no
one ever goes to a music show right like
imagine just being like i'll go see
music and you're a [ __ ] r b fan and
then it's like screamo death metal right
you know i mean that's where comedy is
where it's like no one checks the genre
they're going to see right you know what
i mean so true like yeah okay if you're
the kind of person that is going to get
offended and like go to a newspaper
about this you're probably not going to
be a rich even the other parts of rich
voss's material probably aren't for you
right you know what i mean it's like
just [ __ ] you know it's fun it's
[ __ ] dumb there is a type there's a
genre of comedy that is just like insult
like you know insult comedy that's like
based on just like yeah you know service
level stuff we're all just killing like
if my you know my mom said she wants to
start getting in the podcast i'm not
just gonna actually you know what my mom
mom should watch the show you want to
get into podcasts check out staffy's
podcast
i think you'll really love it no don't
do it nobody wants nobody listen please
stop was one of the funniest things you
guys did and i'm sure you've talked
about this a million times but i've
watched this video a lot just you guys
talking about steven seagal
on the floor
jasmine my girl was like dying left yeah
yeah yeah
they're come town pockets
no segal is a [ __ ] king he's he's
making like i love all dumb action
movies and in fact what you were talking
about you just watched a movie back to
back what i watched back to back this
weekend was den of thieves
is [ __ ] incredible
gerard butler gerard butler
butler
gerard butler looking like a rich voss
fan in that movie just
face swollen alcoholic as hell just like
which one is that i don't know dude it's
basically it's basically like this movie
is fantastic it's quite trash heat
basically okay yes where it's like pablo
schreiber that's the guy he's like he's
like
orange is the new black he's got a bunch
of [ __ ] he's great pablo he's incredible
gerard butler's out and it's just like
it's kind of it's like heat without yeah
yeah yeah one of the first o'shea big
o'shea performances makes it barely
makes sense people are getting [ __ ]
capped left and right left and right
like gerard brothers is just like
50s in there at the end o'shea jackson's
just in a bar like he was in on it the
whole time you have no idea what's going
on it doesn't make any sense but from
the moment it opens
people are cops are getting [ __ ]
head-shotted yeah so sick just like you
ever see that new that netflix movie
that came out last year with chris
helmsworth
i was like yo this is the craziest i
want i watched it back to back i watched
it and then i went on a deep dive on
youtube to find out how they filmed it
all it's wild did you have a look at
that no no dude the guy who gets shot
the guy who with the position
messages
the guy with the beard that like he gets
clipped he's on his team he has like a
beard he's a director
and he's just director of the movie yeah
and this dude filmed the movie with a
camera taped his chest and he would just
if they fell off the roof he'd fall off
the roof with him holding the camera
that's so [ __ ] if they were in a car
chase he was in the back seat and then
like how it would go into another car
another he would jump out run into the
other car with the camera so [ __ ]
crazy dude i love that there's a lot of
there's a lot of like stunt men that are
becoming action directors and you can
tell the movies are getting better john
wick that's what happened the guy who
directed john wick was his stunt
coordinator on the matrix i think yeah
or something like i think maybe not
stunt corner but like
a stunt man maybe his double something
like that and that's why the john wick
movies [ __ ] rule because this guy the
director understands fundamentally the
act like how to capture the action
because that's what's happening all
throughout entertainment and everything
it's like it's all like the stunt man
makes the movie now it's like so for so
long it's like you have some guy or girl
whatever that has nothing to do with the
thing they're creating like you know
they they've never done comedy saying
yeah they're telling you about comedy
well now it's all like you're just
making your own thing totally there was
no dummy from the accounting department
that edited your special yeah yeah you
edited it so that's why it'll be good
yeah same thing with the stuntman stuff
it's like that's why john wick's so good
because it's like it's not some director
that's never rolled around with keanu
reeves before this guy yeah on reeves in
the app
yeah absolutely yeah that was also in
the in the uh overall history i read
the real pain of the matrix dude i mean
same guy who directed um john wick same
guy directed uh
look who's talking because that's right
the second one
the more
napoleon's girlfriend stinky [ __ ] that
google will love that google love that
one
that'll kill you
hello fresh pussycat
[Laughter]
yeah i'm sorry this is what happens
you know this this is just i i take it
to stinky [ __ ]
here's the thing that's the kind of guy
i am yeah because we're not getting you
ring the bell he just starts yelling
come yeah yeah yeah
we literally yeah our text messages are
just talking about me and chris are
going to blow each other on site as soon
as you know
that's that's all that's how we
communicate dude listen i like it on the
patreon
so it was off the chizz arts what's the
special name it's called live at the
lodge room it's on my youtube right now
please subscribe
uh i'm putting a lot of effort in my
youtube channel i post a short clip
every day and then i'll do two to three
longer clips and uh yeah i'm just and
i'm out on i'm actually probably done
the road by now by this time the time
this comes out but you know i'm doing a
fall tour and then i'm doing a big tour
in the winter next year 2023. but yeah
hell yeah poppy you got to see god this
flew by i wish i would love to do i'll
do four more hours with you yeah man
i would have been like stay for the sake
for the next one
i gotta go to the barstool baby
all right fellas ladies
thank you so much this been hey babe
[Music]
baby
um